y la próstata es una glándula masculina
del tamaño de una nuez está ubicada en
la base de la vejiga y envuelve la
uretra
el cáncer de próstata es uno de los
cánceres más comunes en los hombres la
prostatectomía radical es un
procedimiento quirúrgico mediante el
cual se extirpa la próstata el tejido
periférico y las vesículas seminales
dependiendo de su caso el cirujano
además puede optar por extirpar algunos
ganglios linfáticos
antes de someterse a la cirugía se le
colocará una vía endovenosa es posible
que se le administren antibióticos por
vía endovenosa para disminuir las
posibilidades de contraer una infección
se le administrara anestesia general
raquídea o peridural si recibe anestesia
general se le colocará un tubo
respiratorio por la boca y dentro de la
garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación
si recibe anestesia peridural o raquídea
no necesitará un tubo respiratorio se le
administrara un sedante para ayudarle a
relajarse
la prostatectomía radical puede llevar
entre 90 minutos y 4 horas pueden
utilizarse diferentes técnicas
prostatectomía retro pública abierta
prostatectomía perineal abierta y
prostatectomía laparoscópica
en una prostatectomía retro pública
abierta la próstata se extirpa a través
de una incisión que se realiza en la
parte inferior del abdomen en una
prostatectomía perineal la próstata se
extirpa a través de una incisión que se
realiza en el perineo que se encuentra
entre el recto y el escroto en una
prostatectomía laparoscópica
el cirujano inserta los instrumentos en
la cavidad abdominal a través de
pequeñas incisiones en forma de ojo de
cerradura o puertos
el cirujano separa la próstata de su
estructura periférica y extrae la
glándula a través de uno de los puertos
levemente ensancha 2
dependiendo de si el cáncer se ha
diseminado o no es posible que el
cirujano también extirpa el tejido que
rodea a la próstata incluidas las
vesículas seminales y los ganglios
linfáticos independientemente del tipo
de procedimiento
el cirujano revisará detenidamente el
área que rodea la próstata antes de
extraer el tejido teniendo cuidado de
minimizar el daño a los nervios que se
encuentran en esa área al finalizar el
procedimiento quirúrgico se le colocará
un catéter en la vejiga para mantenerla
drenada el catéter generalmente se
dejará en el lugar durante 10 días o
hasta 2 semanas después de la cirugía
poco después de la cirugía se le
retirará el tubo respiratorio y se lo
trasladará al área de recuperación
posquirúrgica para monitorearlo
de ser necesario se le administrarán
calmantes para el dolor es posible que
continúe recibiendo antibióticos por vía
endovenosa es posible que el enjuague en
la vejiga de manera intermitente con una
solución estéril para limpiar la sangre
y los coágulos acumulados la mayoría de
los pacientes son dados de alta a los
dos días del procedimiento